quand on vous vous rendez compte que
vous avez travaillé pendant des années
pour vous constituer un patrimoine et
que vous avez tout perdre en 8 9 mois 1
an
oui l'accès au bout du rouleau on a tout
l'entretien général à suivre à côté de
ça en aide on a été aidé que sur trois
mois et à raison 30% nos dépenses sur
ces mois là donc c'est dérisoire que je
comprends qu'il est contraint de
sanitaires et ça c'est très important
parce que la maladie est là mais il faut
nous aider on peut nous aider c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça à nous
laisser attendre pour quelque chose qui
ne vient pas faut-il rouvrir les
discothèques c'est le gros sujet et vous
allez voir on a peut-être des bonnes
nouvelles pour les patrons de
discothèques
ils vont vous nous en parler dans un
instant christophe longo gérant de boîte
de nuit président du collectif des
discothèques en colère paca corse que
c'est christophe il en a marre et il est
énervé notre christophe extrêmement
énervé et très déçue gouvernance jusqu'à
présent on avait l'impression d'être
méprisés mais a priori comme vous venez
de le dire
à la 30 juin apparemment apparemment en
fait du moins le modem à vos apps a
botté le pass annie terre si on n'était
pas inclus dans le
dans le plein de déconfinement alors
apparemment réouverture avec le pinceau
ni des mois déjà que tu veux montrer pas
servir maintenant tu dois montrer en
place et les rêves radio contré par basa
est déjà très pas déjà de base en plus
maintenant que je montre hasan en
discothèque maintenant tu me connais je
vois un truc
j'espère rester en bagarre giron de
boîte de nuit à aubière dans le
puy-de-dôme commence à la question ça va
pas non plus ça va pas ça fait combien
de semaines quatorze 14 ans à 14 mois
quatorze mois que vous travaillez pas
quatorze mois sans travail sans salaire
comment tu fais là bas je ne sais pas
comment je fais tout de suite j'ai puisé
dans toutes mes économies mais je
voudrais savoir comment on peut faire
sens sans salaire mettez vous à ma place
cinq minutes on se met ça y est je te le
dis qu'il est capable de vivre sans
salaire pendant 14 mois par bernard
montiel
heureusement qui va faire des voilà qui
m'a dit dans des hôtels gratuitement je
vois pas comment on peut faire les mêmes
même nos députés nocéenne non communiste
il avait essayé de rester sans salaire
pendant 2 3 mois par solidarité j'aime y
compris pour vous êtes je vous jure que
c'est vrai on ne parle pas du tout nous
est vraiment les oublier vraiment les
boîtes de nuit à fulham est minoritaire
c'est pour ça qu'on a un gros sentiment
de mépris
aucun moment on parle de nous nous avons
fait des mêmes des propositions de
protocole à un moment donné on nous
avons jamais eu aucune réponse le
meilleur c'est qu'une fois j'ai envoyé
un mail à monsieur virant et c'est le
cabinet monsieur grise et qui m'a
répondu en général quand j'appelle mon
cardiologue ne sais pas non content mais
il est pas mal
jésus bernès ne faut pas ouvrir les
discothèques
non parce j'ai désolé s'en trouveront
très jamais tout simplement non mais
j'en ai un brevet colère mais le lieu
fermé possibilité de contamination lieux
festifs donc même si on met des masques
au début on va les enlever avec la
volonté de se rapprocher donc non je
veux pas faire de démagogie je maintiens
le nom et je crois que vous êtes très
aidés on m'a dit que 80 à 100 dès lors
les aider il faut savoir qu'on a eu les
premières aides au bout de huit mois
les restaurateurs les hauts lieux
immédiatement puis ça va mieux pour eux
deuxièmement on avait sonné pendant les
au début on a eu que quinze mille euros
maximum et s'avérait qu'il ya beaucoup
15 me de ca fais pas le loyer et après à
partir de décembre on a eu 20 % du
chiffre d'affaires ce qui est important
c'est pourquoi la société
le gérant qui est travaillé nos salariés
n'a pas d'être là mais a droit au rsa
c'est ça donc c'est quand même
catastrophique on nous sommes en train
de rentrer dans 14 mois c'est un truc de
fou
christophe ah ben moi que j'ai la chance
j'avais un peu des économies et à la
vision de ma famille qui m'aide
ouais voilà tout simplement pas pensé un
moment fermé tu t'es dit c'est moi où je
vais plus voir ouvrir ben on est sur le
point de tout perdre sans tout aimé
qu'on nous dise parce que le problème
c'est qu'on a joué avec nous pendant
pendant 14 mois c'est à dire que au
départ on nous dit on vous ferme trois
semaines donc on l'a dit trois semaines
c'est pas grave on va faire un coup de
fraîcheur mais un coup de peinture tout
ça on se prépare après on nous a dit
vous allez ouvrir aux autres en kz2 au
30 juin
donc pour le pour le match et on s'est
préparé on a tout nettoyé tout la
discothèque de fond en comble et puis
tous les trois mois on nous a repoussé
donc on a aucune perspective annuelle
jouer avec notamment les seuls qui
n'avait jamais ouvert
j'avais ouvert mais on a joué avec nous
parce qu'ils aient tous les trois mois à
dire vous allez ouvrir bientôt bientôt
et
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'il est pour
les mariages ouais bah dans ce mariage
comment ils vont faire un mille
personnes par rapport à layrisse potec
la raison ils vont pas danser ils vont
patienter
on va demander au roi du dancefloor
autant depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire tout le monde s'en fout des
boîtes de nuit qui sont restés à un lieu
de débauche c'est vrai il sert à rien
alors que c'est pas vrai déjà c'est un
lieu de rencontres et des canadiens
social pour plein de gens et puis c'est
un acteur très important dans l'économie
française contrairement à ce que croient
qu'on peut croire vous n'êtes pas si
minoritaire que soit sa regarder les
chiffres vous avez deux mille boîtes de
nuit en france 1 milliard d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires 100 mille salariés au
sens large dans le monde de la danse et
ça fait en plus gagner de l'argent aux
artistes donc il faut les ouvrir et
maintenant ça alors tu apprécies de ge
au moins la moitié vidéo qui est en
duplex
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces programmes il a semblé céder sur wii
c'est ce à quoi je pense je pense à mes
trois de pegi pegi blanche a dit que ce
que l'on voit mais plus difficile il
faut voir ce que l'on voit c'est pas
d'afl use pourquoi je dis ça en fait
parce que qu'est ce qu'on voit là oui on
voit des gens qui ont été maltraités
pendant un an
ouais on voit quand je dis depuis le
début de cette affaire que ça va mal
finir
et qu'en fait il ya un mépris profond du
peuple français
est-ce que c'est pas des meilleures
maisons s'ils en sont là nous sommes
nous sommes sont deux mecs on ya pire
oui c'est que maintenant pour réouvrir
on va les transformer en policier
sanitaires on va leur demander d'avoir
effectivement un test négatif ici ou un
vaccin mais quel vaccin
astrazeneca est ce qu'ils vont être
effectivement responsable aussi du
variant sud africain et vérifier à
quelle variante donc à un moment donné
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
est-ce qu'on veut reprendre une vie
normale ou est-ce qu'on veut abandonner
considérer que l'on vit au rythme et
finalement degré de ce virus et qu'on
est dans un monde d'après dans lequel la
notion de liberté a été totalement
abolis
[Applaudissements]
mais les mecs
fabrice qui dissout des vérités mais
c'est vrai parce que ces hausses et
fabrice di vizio oui fabrice mais si
l'on résumé t pour les je suis
évidemment pour la réouverture des
discothèques mais sans pass sanitaire
c'est une évidence parce que si on admet
l'idée du pass sanitaire en discothèque
alors ouais jusqu'où on donne l'admettre
et puis quoi on va embaucher des videurs
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire
il sait que gatti on va les attendait et
s'ils sont négatifs on les ferme
non mais les agapes du vide la gilles
verdez et géraldine mamet bull dit c'est
tous les soirs une lettre les ayatollahs
d'un costume sans révéler les deux noms
mais sa version il fait comme une houe
également pour rigoler et ont fait
ployer reçoit justement pour pas rester
dans la nuit pour pouvoir aller en boîte
de nuit même si je suis très vieille non
effectivement pour reprendre une vie un
peu plus normale et nécessaire en
dix-neuf d'épaisseur
un truc bien sûr ça moi ce que je
voudrais juste vous dire c'est que dès
qu'il va y avoir une discothèque où il
va y avoir un cluster toutes les
discothèques vont fermer sur ces mois
terminée du moins tant que le passage
vers c'est peut-être une alternative
pour commencer à ce que les gens
viennent chez vous et puis lancez vous
avez quand même des gens nommés du tube
et du dominiquin c'est un bon tu vois ça
tu as de péter un micro et ma famille
c'est pas le moment le service je sais
que l'essor pardon mais se détendre
c'est de dire que les que les gens
peuvent venir les discothèques avec un
masque vous savez bien que ça me tient
bien la route mais un détour inverse on
parle on danse mais dont c'était la
raison d'un métissage entreprises on est
des perf a mis en veilleuse de l'équité
c'est tout parce que je rentrais dans
toutes les boîtes aux lettres vous
voulez pas de les arrêter ni terre vous
voulez pas de l'équité vous voulez vivre
voilà exactement ce qu'ils veulent dire
mais excusez moi excusez moi mais faut
qu'on arrête d'employer des mots qui
servent à rien et on veut de l'équité de
la justice banon vous voulez bouffer
vous voulez effectivement qu'un maison
mais ces victoires bâties
non mais ici c'est incompatible parce
que tant qu'on appellera aux grands
principes
effectivement on aura des discours
philosophique alors les social tout le
tarn est oui alors gilles verdez m
division c'est de la démagogie pure moi
je vais vous poser une question
vous avez des enfants les discothèques
ou vos enfants vous disent on va en
boîte vous dites quoi sinon j
ces deux étudiants à la maison tout de
suite tu me vois pas les enseignantes
les empêcher de sortir et surtout une
chose les mises en chantier pour tous
ses habitants
ils ont fait rêver et 18 ans je sais une
chose importante
les jeunes on va pas les empêcher de
sortir ils vont aller surfer en effet
nous vivons beaucoup sur le comptant
bien sûr mais surtout il faut savoir du
moins dans notre région à nous comme
dans beaucoup d'endroits les soirs il ya
des soirées clandestines qui sont
organisées par des dealers bien phu la
drogue l'alcool à foison et 5 contres et
sant est ça n'a pas habilités les cinq
gestes barrières ne faut-il pas mieux
nous faire confiance aux aimants c'est
pourquoi ça fait confiance à vous les
jeunes et si j'avais des enfants de
l'âge voilà de vos enfants avouent
l'année irait mieux
je vous dis franchement je préfère
qu'ils aillent en discothèque plus haut
qu'ils aillent dans des soirées ils vont
pas du tout être missiles sur des zones
qui m'a appelé pour savoir qu'un jour
ouvré parce que je venais juste celle
berda sur un point je comprends
parfaitement la position qui est la
vôtre mais simplement il ya un effet que
vous maîtrisez pas il a été démontré par
des études très sérieuses et l'effet
pâte à modeler salle un crible à c'est
exactement scientifiquement on démontre
que fermer en fait nous empêcherait
jamais les gens de se réunir il fait
patate à dire qu'à un moment donné soit
vous contrôler ce qui s'y passe soit
effectivement envers hervé en veillant
un peu soit concrètement va vous laisser
les choses se faire de manière sauvage
les gens voient là vont venir avec des
passagers
et voilà c'est n'a pas apprécié des
faits docteur maboule mais compris si je
ne suis pas sûr que vous soyez très
calés sur les discothèques
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je suis pour la rouverture par
principe pour que effectivement vous
viviez en revanche on peut pas comparer
une discothèque et des magasins qui
ouvre la mobilisation les yaya le fait
que ce soit un endroit fermé donc moi je
suis pour la rouverture mais c'est vrai
que se construise de produits lambda
j'étais là il ya 10 minutes
oui ce qu'ils ont comparées au mariage
mais des mariages qui est intéressant à
jouer se marient le 19 juin est inexact
mais ça va mais rossi fait des
confitures en norvège il faut regarder
ce qui se passe autour de l'os il ya
plein de pays y compris des pays plus
fort de la terreur
les boîtes sont ouverts en espagne les
boîtes sont ouverts aux états unis dans
certaines villes les boîtes sont ouverts
en asie les boîtes sont ouverts et sans
pas sanitaires on est le pire pays le
plus sévère avec patrick jane le passé
ni terre en tant que c'est à la mode
mais si c'est juste si c'est une
solution non revenir à la normale et moi
honnêtement ça ne revienne pas sur moi
comme géraldine si on le prend vacciner
justement pour retrouver un sentier vous
chaque fois des bijoux très dur à ce
point si vous permettez
voilà je comprends parfaitement cette
logique qu'ils puissent être de dire
pour revenir à la normale on va accepter
un certain nombre mais on va les
accepter combien de temps et on va
accepter jusqu'où est ce que demain
matin il parlait des mariages c'est
intéressant
votre fille se marie je la soumettrai un
vestiaire et si on soumettait à un
vaccin et jusqu'où jeudi aux invalides à
quel moment est-ce qu'on va décider que
peut-être il est temps ça fait un an et
demi elles ont fermé est ce que ça a
empêché tout master de ce créneau que ça
empêcher concrètement les pinots de
saturer
je vais vous poser sa copie je vous
présente ce qui nous défendons n'a pas
l'aura de des fonds privés
pas payer d'abord je chasse et du gie
d'abord jeunes belges face personne j'ai
compris d'un point de vue ensuite
effectivement deuxième élément moi j'ai
une question quand même à vous poser
c'est si vous avez à ce point peur que
discothèque sur des lieux de
contamination est bien très bien mais
reste garde on sait comment ce que
disait regardons ce qu'il s'est passé
ailleurs est-ce qu'au texas aujourd'hui
nous avons une reprise de l'épidémie est
ce qu'en espagne
nous avons des clusters au sein des
discothèques alors quoi vous fondez-vous
passé ils se font sur rien c'est dit les
problèmes de fond si vous voulez c'est
que vous vivez sous une dictature c'est
jusqu'au bout sa dictature la dictature
de la peur est celle là ah oui larsson
que je vous en libérer je pense que
c'est ça le problème
je parle effectivement aujourd'hui vous
avez peur de vivre et aujourd'hui il est
bon de vivre
vous ne pouvez plus être dans une
logique où survivre à la vie à moitié
c'est plus possible ses matches et lives
et dvd sur l'hypothèque
c'est comme si on demandait à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas le permis
ce que nous voulons penser oui
j'aimerais qu'ils lisent ou de cette
histoire de passe-passe sanitaire
chambéry guillaume est une espèce de ça
va être une espèce de disque est sur du
long terme j'ai l'impression je suis moi
c'est ça qui me fait flipper jamais
après tout ce qui est des boîtes de nuit
moi j'ai surtout l'impression que le
gouvernement n'ait pas assez jeune pour
se pencher sur le sujet parce qu'ils ont
généralement du mal à 50 jours
roulers et 4,15 sur la piste j'ai donné
aux discothèques pendant ses années
d'études à nous sommes pas foncièrement
juin de sciences la prada les latins son
nom mais s'il vous plaît là comme on a
des nouvelles
il paraît que ça rouvrirait le 1er
juillet ce que vous êtes content avec la
wii déjà dans sa besace en sensations ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est très bien quand
même parce qu'il faut oublier qu'on
travaille
il faut qu'on travaille ça vous dérange
ou pas non nous on veut travailler tous
par quoi qu'il faut être conscient que
ça va pas être facile parce que pas tout
le monde sera forcément dax signé au
début et pas tous les jeunes voudront
faire un test pcr deux fois par semaine
bien sûr être honnête je dis qu'après y
aura une discussion maintenant je
demande d aide peut-être s'y opère et on
est prêts on oublie juillet fawar ça va
être bon au 1er juillet c'est bon on va
ouvrir les boîtes de nuit il semble que
l'issue de ces 5 min 0 kg haut et que je
vienne faire un deux trois sets 0 h et
par mariage de la belle il faut que je
deviendrais gratuitement je rigole avec
le mariage de la fille d'isabelle à
mettre des masques une distance à
sciences sociales et que parce que quand
on est en famille le problème ils ont
fait confiance aux gens et on dit d'un
moment on oublie de le dire je me dis à
personne
ce que j'espère ici c'est que plus
personne ne tient la ccry sociale quand
même j'espère qu'on a tous conscients
laver la raison j'espère que ce
conscience qu'avec deux tests pcr pour
aller en discothèque c'est à lui à la
droite pourrait la gauche ça sert bonne
augure bien
c est ma division un test pcr ça coûte
combien j'en sais rien à richert c
c'est ouais mais c'est énorme j'en sais
rien ça va ça va être une catastrophe à
l'appui à la paix tout senti qu vide à
partir de 18 ans et vous savez que les
clubs libertins sont ouverts non non et
charlize libertas après la bonne
nouvelle tombait à la montée comme
libertas un club où il croise une mylène
farmer n'a pas trop le coup comme situé
rue est une ferme les boîtes de nuit et
qu'on autorise les clubs libertins a par
définition du club libertin il ya un
rapprochement donc vraiment oui non moi
je préfère que les jeunes aient affaire
à des professionnels de la nuit comme
version de faire des fêtes sauvages
n'importe où n'importe comment ou là il
ya du cluster edit c'est ce que tend
bien dans l'histoire décret ouvre bien
sûr c'est vrai tank est une danseuse
non j'y vais plus enfin la dose voilà
j'aime la danse d'autres beauxis ici
beaucoup allé aussi en discothèque et
les jeunes ont le droit de détail c'est
que la loi oblige aux discothèques
d'avoir un système de ventilation exact
mais minutes et que l'air elle est
récompensée comme dans le slip de bain
d'un moto depuis le début et ça peut
être d'aller sur votre coiffeur l'air
est pas le renouveler toutes les 8
minutes en jeu contre vous
[Rires]